what happens if you have a state change
the law saying that that children who
are lgbtq can't be in classrooms with
other children
is that is that legit under the way the
decision is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
in recent american history
that's your mind muddled president joe
biden i'm your humble rumble youtube
blaze tv host dave rubin it is may 5th
2022. this is the ruben report direct
message we're live streaming on the
usual places do me a favor and subscribe
if you have not
and jesus that guy is just
absolutely the worst we are gonna unpack
that video and juxtapose it with joe
biden from a year ago and uh not only is
joe biden a lot slower than he was a
year ago he looks a lot worse i mean the
guy is becoming more and more decrepit
right in front of our faces he has gone
from mr unity to mr uh
uh
where am i but i'll tell you where i'm
gonna be guys on june 2nd this year less
than one month from right now i'm going
to the belly of the beast right here in
florida i'm going to orlando with this
guy you might heard of him the governor
ron desantis that's right ruben and
desantis at the plaza live in orlando
june 2nd i'm going to do my thing my
solo thing little stand up little
messing with the crowd a little bit of a
talk
for about 40 minutes and then the
governor will join me on stage for an
interview for another 45 vip meet and
greet all that good stuff you can go to
davereuben.com
events if you would like to join us uh
we will be talking about joe biden today
and the one i found one we did a
tremendous amount of research and i want
to thank you guys for all the research
you did this morning we found one sane
democrat we did it we did it i lost a
bet we found one sane democrat uh we're
going to be getting to all that and then
today of course because it's thursday is
a reuben report locals community q a and
we got a lot of good stuff so i'm
psyched for the show today real quick i
want to talk to you guys about
expressvpn you know watching netflix
without using expressvpn is like going
to a casino and only being able to play
on the slot machines why limit yourself
like that the big money somewhere else
netflix has different content libraries
for every country netflix's thousands of
shows but without a vpn you can only get
access to a fraction of that based on
your location let you you can change
your online location control where you
want netflix or other streaming websites
to think you're located wherever you
want to be while using expressvpn i've
been watching all sorts of stuff i
mostly watch seinfeld but you can watch
it from different countries too that's
pretty good you just open up the app
select united states as your country tap
one button to connect and then when you
refresh the page it's right there why
choose expressvpn over other competitors
you can gain access to thousands of new
shows thanks to their servers in 94
countries and you can stream in hd with
zero buffering so be smart stop paying
full price for streaming services and
only getting access to a fraction of
their content get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com ruben don't forget to use
my link at expressvpn.comruben
to get an extra three months of
expressvpn absolutely free okay so we
normally don't do a cold open and then i
throw right back to that cold open but i
think it's worth mentioning once again
because joe biden yesterday
he's just terrible he's just terrible
he's a liar he doesn't know what he's
saying
he's a little bit of a liar a little bit
doesn't know what he's saying a little
bit of a prime political manipulator and
a little bit of just like a buffoon who
reads whatever's put in front of him
but here is a bit of his response to
what's going on with this roe v wade
reversal and how mean the rest of us are
what happens if you have a state change
the law saying that that
children who are lgbtq can't be in
classrooms with other children
is that is that legit under the way the
decision is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
in recent american history
well
he did clean it up with recent american
history otherwise he might have been
talking about his own democrat party
which of course is the party of slavery
but putting that aside for just a moment
first off it's just pure nonsense um
some of the nuts and bolts parts of this
i mentioned this yesterday but in the
elito brief that was released they
specifically talk about how this
decision
is only effective to this abortion case
meaning roe v wade it has no precedent
related to any other case that's number
one number two in terms of this that
they're going to discriminate
discriminate and not allow lgbt kids in
classes with other kids we already have
anti-discrimination laws we have the
equal protection laws clause um
you cannot do that like it's completely
against the constitution
he's conflating these issues because
this is all they've got all they've got
is absolute
ridiculous fear you cannot discriminate
against a student or a free citizen of
this society based on the color of their
skin or their gender or sexual identity
you simply cannot do it it is completely
against
the constitution as it is written is it
it is against the bill of rights it's
against all of all of the laws that we
have but he knows that and again all
that roe v wade's reversal is doing is
kicking it back to the states and most
states are going to have
abortion right most of them like florida
which just passed this 15-week thing
which is a somewhat
doesn't matter what you think about
abortion that would be considered a
compromise some people want nine month
abortion some people want no abortions
so okay 15 weeks that's what florida
said to very little fanfare and states
are going to do that i think the florida
model is going to be a somewhat moderate
model that we'll see throughout i don't
know maybe 20 or 30 states and then
there'll be five or seven uh very red
states that will do something more
closer to what texas is doing at six
weeks uh or maybe no abortion except for
the most extreme exceptions and then
there'll be blue states that will allow
for 12-month
abortions you know four months india
like the kid gavin newsom will come to
your house and kill the kid they'll
decapitate him for you um so that allows
a plurality of opinion and all that good
stuff but the real reason i wanted to
play that clip wasn't about the abortion
part it's what he said the maga crowd is
so extreme the maga crowd is so extreme
i went uh to
maga central last night i went to
mar-a-lago in west palm beach florida it
was the debut of dinesh d'souza's new
movie 2000 mules which is
all about election fraud and he lays out
quite an interesting case and i highly
recommend uh that you guys check out the
movie which i believe debuts tomorrow if
i'm not mistaken and it was a who's who
of right-wing mania from larry elder and
dennis prager to seb gorka and the
orange man himself donald trump and
marjorie taylor green and rob smith and
dave rubin and all of these scary people
and they were all there and everybody
was kind of smiling and enjoying
themselves i had a little bit of tequila
it's quite a nice evening uh i mentioned
that
because uh if the maga crowd is the most
extreme
in memory or he's then still you know he
filled it in with recent memory um then
then we should be just fine because
actually the maga thing or whatever the
republican party seems to be morphing
into instead of just a bunch of pet
republicans that go on msnbc and get
patted on the head and fed a cookie oh
can i have another you know these sort
of mitt romney do-nothing liz cheney
losers they're becoming people who
actually fight back they're becoming a
new breed of republican who stand up for
what they believe in who fight the
system the ron desantis model uh jd
vance just winning the republican
primary in ohio blake masters was there
last night who's going to win
the primary in arizona the senate
primary in arizona and carrie lake i had
on the show a few weeks ago who's
running for governor and i'm pretty sure
he's going to win governor in arizona
these are people who are standing up and
fighting uh and they're not extremists
they don't hate gay people they don't
hate women they have beliefs and they're
standing up for them and because when
you get a bunch of republicans standing
up for what they believe in that scares
democrats and they don't really have
much to to go on there's not much if
you're a democrat right now you don't
have much to go on right you can't be
like oh well the inflation thing and the
supply chain thing and the war thing and
the gas thing and the border thing it
could start getting weird so you just
have to go their extremists their races
their bigots etc etc but all of that
being said you know i like to give the
devil his due and i said dave the
democrats can't be all insane can we
find a democrat a sane democrat and i
sent my people out this morning i sent
them out we put the scent of an old
democrat on them put it right there then
we said find me a democrat a same
democrat and we actually did
uh find one saying democrat oh but you
know what we should show you the other
piece i guess before we do that so that
was biden
yesterday right that was biden yesterday
saying that these people are evil and
everything else but now let's show you
joe biden the day after the election or
when he finally accepted the nomination
back in november of 2020 talking about
how you know we should all come together
it's a little bit different than joe
biden of yesterday for all those of you
who voted for president trump
i understand the disappointment tonight
i've lost a couple times myself but now
let's give each other a chance
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature
see each other again listen to each
other again
and to make progress we have to stop
treating our opponents as our enemies
they are not our enemies they are
americans
all right so that was joe biden about a
year and a half ago
he was going to bring us all together
right and first off also just look at
him he looks way
way healthier now real quick i already
showed it to you twice but one more time
this is joe biden yesterday what happens
if you have a state changes the law
saying that that that children who are
lgbtq can't be in classrooms with other
children
is that is that legit under the way the
decision is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
in recent american history i mean
putting aside the drivel and the lies
and the nonsense and the fear monger i
mean just the way the guy has aged alone
i mean he's he's aged 30 years right
despite the facelifts and the hair plugs
and the botox and whatever they've done
to his eyes and his teeth and the whole
like they've done all of that and he has
just aged absolutely horribly but anyway
putting all of that aside i said there
must be a sane democrat find me a sane
democrat
and gosh darn it we actually found one
it's worse than ridiculous sean it is
absolutely despicable and outrageous
when you look at the president of the
united states of america calling
millions of americans essentially
terrorists people who politically
opposed him or voted against him he's
calling them terrorists in an attempt to
intimidate them into silence and we know
this is because we've heard this before
from both him and his attorney general
you'll remember when when his attorney
general said you know anyone who holds
extremist or anti-authority views will
be targeted for investigation and
potential prosecution by their domestic
terrorist unit so he's essentially
saying that this quote-unquote maga
crowd
are worse than terrorists this is
outrageous and so for every american
who's watching every american who's seen
this no matter how you feel about the
maga crowd this is an authoritarian
assault on our freedom and we need to
stand together very strongly against
this attempt to intimidate and silence
anyone who holds political views that
are different from or opposed to what
this president and his administration
are furthering this is an assault on our
democracy
right that's very exciting a sane
democrat of course she's a democrat who
hillary clinton said was a russian asset
who the party completely kicked out of
the way who's no longer a congresswoman
from hawaii and i don't know if she has
a future in the democratic party or even
in politics uh because politics is a
dirty game and she's actually a decent
human being that's tough but i did while
she was talking i wrote down i'm going
to come up with a list of saying
democrats say never tulsi and i put an
exclamation point
to really drive it home there is one
sane democrat very exciting all right
before we get to the q a i want to talk
to you guys about relief band you know
is joe biden and the democrats
disastrous policy making you nauseous
that was a great segue did you know that
one out of three americans regularly
suffer from nausea i hate to say it but
i'm getting older it's true and whether
it's taking a road trip riding a roller
coaster or even side effects for
medications nausea is becoming more of a
regular part of life if nausea is
getting in the way of enjoying life it's
of life's important moments i've got
good news you've got to check out relief
band relief man's the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that's
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangover
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more how it works is relief band
stimulates a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick
it's like the name says it's
legitimately a band you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea and
anxiety and you can change the intensity
depending on how you're feeling to make
it stronger or weaker it's that simple
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through relief band it's available to
the masses plus the product's 100 drug
free non-drowsium provides all natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed and they
just released their newest model relief
band sport the sport is waterproof has
extended battery life and you and can
even attach to your apple or android
watch don't let the fear of nausea
prevent you from being present for
life's important moments right now you
can join over a hundred thousand relief
band users with an exclusive offer just
for the reuben report audience if you go
to reliefman.com and use promo code
ruben you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee remember it's better to have a
relief ban and not need it than to need
it and not have it so head on over to r
e l i e f b a and d dot com and use my
promo code ruben for 20 off plus free
shipping and now back to me all right
reuben report locals q a here we go anya
says after your visit at mar-a-lago what
do you who do you think will be the best
candidate for president now so trump
came out before the movie
and he talked for about 20 minutes and i
have to say it's good seeing the guy and
you know he gets out there he's got a
couple zingers there was media there and
he makes fun of the media and he's given
shout outs around the room and rudy was
right up front and you know all the all
the usual cast of characters was there
you know he was he was really focused
last night because of the movie and the
purpose of the movie which was election
fraud trump was really focused on
election fraud i think what trump and
the republicans are going to have to
figure out is is that a winning ticket
now you can argue it either way it's
like if you really believe that there
was fraud and the movie does make quite
a case and i hope you will see it i hope
you'll see it and make a judgment call
for yourself and i probably should get
let's get dinesh on to to talk about the
movie um
then then trump has to solve some of the
stuff if he's gonna run right you can't
say oh they stole the election from me
they do all this stuff here's all of the
stuff they do but i haven't fixed any of
the stuff or we haven't done anything to
stop it from happening again so i'm just
running again then it doesn't really
make sense to run again the other issue
that trump is gonna have to address and
i say again i say this as somebody that
likes trump um is you know if he runs
you take a pretty depressed democrat
base because everything is so whacked
out right now and you fire them up
because like five million people
probably vote who wouldn't vote
otherwise just because they hate trump
so that's just a reality that he has to
figure out and and i think he's he and
his people probably are thinking what
they have to do with it the real
question is where does desantis fall
into this it feels like it's desantis's
moment he's he's been by far the best
governor in the united states i would
argue in many ways he's been the real
president and the real leader of the
country uh for the last two years he's
the model for how this whole thing is
supposed to work
and uh you know he's got to win this
thing in florida his own reelection here
in november and then and then from there
if he can really really solidify the
state if the state looks freaking strong
and it feels like it's going in that
direction like florida really is going
going the right way then maybe he wants
to make the move but i can also say this
i've met him a few times and and he
loves florida like he really loves
florida that's not to say he doesn't
love america but he loves florida i
don't know that he has ambitions beyond
that uh you know also his wife just
recovered from cancer she's fully
recovered thank god and they have two
young kids like he may not want to be in
in the mix i don't know however i will
be sitting down with him on june 2nd in
orlando and perhaps i will ask him that
very question but that's going to be the
decision that the republicans are going
to have to make could there be a sit
down between trump and desantis could
trump be the bodyguard or sort of the
linebacker and let
desantis run right through as the
running back like there's there's
questions out there but either one of
them would obviously be far better than
dementia man and the crazy lady
pete says are you going to miss boomers
when we're gone
um
well first off you know even though i
make fun of joe biden and i make fun of
nancy pelosi
and some of these people
and i talk about their age it's not
because i don't respect old people i've
actually always loved old people i
really do i always had great
relationships with my grandparents and
great grandparents i had two i had a
great grandfather longer than i had a
grandfather um i my favorite show is the
golden girls i've always loved old
people you can learn a lot from old
people oh people have been through it
and they might know a little bit of
something right um
the boomer generation is interesting my
parents are boomers obviously i'm a gen
xer the boomer generation is interesting
because they're they're seemingly
hanging on
too long to the power thing right you
want people to live a long hopefully
health uh healthy actualized life
hopefully well into their 80s 90s etc
and beyond if they can do it in a
decent capacity um
the set of people at a political level
that are hanging on need to let go
and i don't know if that's because
science has extended lives maybe it's
because social media has ever made
everyone feel younger or more connected
or something but these people need to go
away so i would separate just the
average person my aunts and uncles and
my parents who i love who are good
boomers who are great people who i hope
stick around for a long time versus the
political class of boomers who just have
to get
out of the way you don't have to go home
but you can't stay here you gotta get
out of the way and make room
for say some of the gen xers to finally
take charge like this was this
transition was supposed to happen 10
years ago and you guys have stuck around
for too long i mean really
like the pelosi thing is so interesting
because i also think they're believe it
or not are differences between men and
women and the idea that nancy pelosi had
80 something years old with all the
money she has and everything else that
she's running for re-election again
i don't know can we see how many
grandkids does nancy pelosi have it's
like however many she has whether it's
one or nine
um it's like go be a grandmother lady go
be a grandmother and and enjoy the kids
and cook and do whatever it is what do
whatever it is you do but why do you
feel the need to get dressed in your
pantsuits and put on the ridiculous
makeup and make your eyebrows higher and
higher and talk to people about how they
should live their life she has nine
grandkids but she'd rather be out there
uh you know controlling your life than
spending time with her own grandchildren
i suspect they don't like her very much
i mean imagine seeing nancy pelosi like
late at night grandma babysitting you
and she walks into the room and she
smells like booze ah the children the
children
asa says when i was younger i was pretty
hardcore pro-choice
that changed for me when i heard my
oldest heartbeat and saw his sonogram
for the first time i thought i was
miscarrying my youngest at 16 weeks and
i panicked thinking i was losing my baby
i do not think there should be an
outright ban on abortion but i am but i
am finally limiting uh to the first
trimester wondering if seeing the
sonograms for your babies has affected
your thinking well i've talked about
this a little bit and i wrote about it
in both books
you know going through the process of
all of this and literally seeing the
moment the sperm meets the egg and that
a day later they can tell you if it's a
male or female and then seeing the
sonogram and seeing cells divide and
then eventually it's starting to form
and then you see the beginnings of what
look like a human being because it is a
human being and then seeing brain
activity and the heartbeat appointment
and all of these things you know it's
real you know it's real so your
experience that you're describing right
there it's like everyone that's had a
kid has gone through that not
necessarily you know when you do it
through ivf you're obviously seeing
things a lot earlier
that's just how science works um because
and also you know you know what's
happening much earlier often people get
pregnant they don't know about they may
not know for two months even so you can
see a lot more um but what you're
talking about about the compromise there
is the interesting unsaid thing and it's
what i've been trying to explain to
people
about this roe v wade thing it's like
this isn't really about abortion exactly
it's hard to really understand that
because it's hard to see
it's hard to see the full picture here
because everyone is so crazy right
this is really about states rights that
you would just give the opportunity for
people in states to decide what they
want to do and then if you don't like it
you can either move or if you want to
have a medical procedure done in another
state then you can go do it and then
people like gavin newsom and rich
hollywood celebrities can pay for other
people to come to their states and have
abortions if they think it is so
wonderful but i really believe this that
even though i know tons tons tons and
perhaps most of my audience at this
point
is is pro
life
and is not for abortion when you have
sit down private conversations with
people most people that i've talked to
even some people that wouldn't want me
to say it publicly so i'm not going to
throw anyone under the bus understand
that there is a difference between a few
weeks in and that that cell's dividing
versus the human form versus the
heartbeat and all that and that's not to
acknowledge that obviously the sperm
eating egg like that's the beginning of
life it is there has to be a beginning
if there's a beginning that's the
beginning but that there's a difference
between the cells dividing
and the blastocyst and say
6 8 10 20 weeks in the bill that the
democrats are pushing right now
literally right now
that chuck schumer is pushing is for
unlimited abortions at any time due to
the physical or mental health of the
woman so that means that a woman eight
months pregnant who's suddenly freaking
out could have an abortion with a
perfectly healthy fetus
uh these these are the extremists it's
not the republicans right now who are
the extremists when it comes to abortion
i will give the republicans a little bit
of a tip here if you want to get some
wins here maybe what republicans should
be doing is start funding some things
privately not through the government so
that let's say there is a woman out
there who's on the fence about the
abortion but she's also very concerned
that she doesn't have the resources to
take care of this baby so she's leaning
towards having an abortion there could
be more funding private organizations
that say hey we will help you get
through the pregnancy and we will do our
best to find a safe a happy home for
that baby now there are some
organizations that do that but if there
was ever a time to double down on that
say hey we will put our money where our
mouth is we don't want these babies
killed we will do more to
let you get that baby to term and then
take care of that baby in life like that
would be something that would be
something but right now it's the
democrats who are the extremists on this
it's not the republicans
if ben says if you could get bill maher
to understand one thing assuming you're
ever allowed back on his show what would
it be well back you say back on his show
i've never been on the show they've
canceled me three times on real time uh
i was booked three times they've
canceled me three times and then i was
supposed to be on his new podcast twice
and they've canceled me twice i think
they just kind of string me along so
that i'm not too mean to him here i've
kind of just had it like i honestly
don't i just don't care that much
anymore like i'm doing my thing i like
what i'm doing
if i cross paths with them great like
you guys know my feelings about the guy
um if i could get him to understand one
thing i mean it would basically be
uh dude you got to the end of liberalism
and at the end of liberalism is the same
conservative or go backwards and go
backwards and still believe that
everyone's racist uh you know still
still call for a recession when it's
trump in office and then and then be
upset that there's a recession now when
it's the guy you voted in
um
at the end of
at the end of where these liberals get
is either a really confused miserable
person or someone who just ends up
repeating conservative talking points
two years later i guess i got to the end
of the road and uh and that's why a lot
of liberals that would talk to me five
years ago won't talk to me anymore
that's just fine that actually is
completely fine i didn't get into this
for friends my best friend to this day
as my buddy john who's my tour manager
on the uh on the tour uh we met the
first day of kindergarten uh and i've
got other friends so that's just fine
and i've got new friends out of this
whole thing um so you know people move
on it's all good but mar it's just like
man get there already like get there i
just know enough of these people and i
know what they
believe privately but it would be very
hard as i've said many times it would be
very hard for a guy like him to be like
hey yes i've been screaming about
liberalism all these years but the truth
is that i have to vote republican to
save liberalism it's like it's just a
bridge too hard for a hollywood guy
taylor says i talk daily with my 92 year
old mother who believes everything she
hears on cnn and msnbc while we don't
talk much about politics there's a very
large angry thing between us it's awful
awful awful how do you manage with your
loved ones uh
this is like the toughest one right it
is the toughest one we all have versions
of this in our own families and with
friends and everything else
and it's why
knowing what you think and trying to
calmly explain things to people is so
important but but more than that there
are things that are more important than
politics and that's why
as politics has become cult-like and
it's become religion for people and they
wake up and just it's endless politics
you know
um it makes people crazy politics is a
really dirty game it's a it's a game
about how to manage people and people
think all sorts of different things and
we have to have some political system
that exists so we're not total
anarchists right you need something
um
and if but if you only believe in that
instead of believing in something bigger
than that and and something that has
existed long before us and that will
exist long after than us
you're gonna go nuts and um and that's
why the obsession with politics you know
i see this with a lot of people that no
matter what they always want to talk
about politics i even have friends and
people in my life that i don't want to
talk politics with or i can do it for
everyone wants to talk politics with me
right wherever i go people want to talk
politics i go to a dinner party people
want to talk politics anywhere i go
people want to talk politics i can
always do it and i enjoy the hell out of
it often and it can get very heated and
i enjoy that or will agree on stuff and
that's fine too whatever it is and i can
do it in big groups and small groups and
all that
but i don't need to do it all the time
and i always go out of my way to tell
people you know we don't have to just
talk politics whatever you want we can
talk about sports we can talk about
music we can talk about kids we can talk
about gardening we can talk about
literally anything
but this obsessive need to whittle down
everything to politics is and it's also
something that is much
it's much more a part of the leftist
mindset than it is a conservative
mindset that's for sure when i was part
of left everything came down to politics
always
this because it's about controlling
people so and and that that desire for
control will make you focus on it all
the time conservatives more broadly they
don't want to control people as much and
because if you don't want to control
people that much if you understand that
people are a little bit different and if
you understand that the government is
not supposed to own everybody um you're
okay with more differences so when i've
had you know dinner parties with 20
people let's say more
conservative-leaning people it's like
we're talking positive but we're
laughing the whole time we're laughing
and we're having a blast and we're
making fun of each other when we have
differences but if you do that with a
bunch of liberals it's people storming
out of the table it's people slamming
their glasses down and leaving early and
yelling at each other i know you all
know this we all know this so i i i'm
sorry you're going through it it's and
and you know your mom's up there in
years and there's a limited amount of
time left
and um
do your best not to i mean just change
the channel or cancel her cable cancel
her cable that's what you got to do
get her watching the golden girls
instead of cnn nothing good is coming
out of that
ashland says dave what will be the
ribbon or color that everyone will start
wearing to protest roe v wade cue the
iranian flags being being taken down and
replacing today right we had everyone
had to post the black image for blm then
everyone had to post the ukrainian flag
for ukraine or the blue image what will
it be for roe v wade i don't know like a
pin of like just like a six month
aborted baby is that too too much
too much move it's just pink and yeah
peter says did david's cooking change
after moving states i mean ingredients
and cuisine must be different in florida
what do you think of it so far had a
grilled alligator yet i will tell you
one pain point that we're having here in
florida which is that our house
is located in an area where we don't
have natural gas they don't have natural
gas on the streets so our stove is
electric and chefs ask any chef that you
know or any if you watch any cooking
show or anyone that loves to cook
everyone loves a gas stove right you
want to turn on that fire you want to
really be able to control that fire even
me david loves to cook up but i do enjoy
cooking but even for me like to be able
to control the fire properly is such a
key piece of cooking right you're
sauteing something and you can see the
flame so we have an electric stove so
you know an electric stove it's just
like it's sort of like that glass panel
and it just gets super hot it's a little
harder to control i know some people
like it and there's a simplicity to it
or something but it's not like the full
thing that that chefs generally like so
actually we're in the middle the guy was
here this morning
we're trying to figure out a way to get
a propane tank
here like put underground so that we can
replace the stove and get a gas range
because he hasn't been enjoying cooking
as much so he's he's kind of eased up on
that but he's working on a lot of house
projects and you know we're trying to
build nurseries for the babies and a
whole bunch of other stuff and just get
life in order so that we can uh you know
have expand this family and do it in a
functional way our house is kind of
modern so it's very there's a lot of
sharp corners everywhere apparently i've
been told babies don't like sharp
corners and a lot of stairs so we got to
soften up this place a little bit um so
he's been cooking a little bit less
actually
but for those of you that follow on
locals i mean i love this big green egg
smoker so i'm smoking things left and
right whether it's steaks or salmon or
lamb uh we've been doing a little more
pasta and salads and all that kind of
stuff but once we get the stove in he'll
he'll get back to it and no we have not
had alligator yet i did once have frog
frog's legs i thought it was chicken
fingers turned out to be frogs that was
in texas uh freebird says does it seem
to you that any time where uh anytime we
middle of the road americans get any
glimmer of hope that something will pull
us as a society back to something close
to normal something else happens we come
out squinting from our covid hibernation
cave to find ukraine we cautiously
celebrate elon musk and right away
scotus scandal there have been many such
instances in the past several years is
it a coincidence am i paranoid i don't
think you're paranoid and i've been
trying to make a point of that
that's why i keep saying how does the
machine always stay one step ahead of us
that's why i always say you've got to
give the devil's due this thing always
keeps us in it even if you think about
think about the two weeks before i went
out on tour so i wasn't in studio it was
like we had win after win after win
whether it was desantis taking out
disney and really exposing the nonsense
of the of the gender crew right uh
whether it was elon musk getting twitter
uh whether it was judge mazzell uh
flipping the mask mandate uh this 35
year old trump appointed judge that no
one had ever heard of and then suddenly
everyone just takes off their masks and
things start getting back to normal we
had all these wins and things were
feeling really good as i've been saying
we're in this post-woke world i really
still think we are and it doesn't mean
it's not going to have growing pains but
we are there but you're right then
suddenly out of nowhere out of nowhere
abortion and roe v wade just gets thrown
on top of all of us and we're now
staring at that we're all looking at
that instead of looking at all the other
stuff whether it's the bad stuff
inflation supply chain blah blah blah or
whether it's all the good stuff that i
just referred to we're all just now
focused on abortion you've got all the
people angry again you've got the base
starting to get out in the streets again
and you can feel the anger and the
temperature going up and it's like man
the temperature was actually going down
there was a relief people were smiling
again on airplanes like things were
happening the machine does weird things
and i think we really really really got
to figure out who did this leak how what
were their connections with politico and
this journalist and everything else like
is barely a day and a half has gone by
since this thing leaked almost no one's
talking about the leaker anymore or the
hunt for the leaker this is this is an
extraordinary escalation you if we are
to have a society that has any respect
for laws and rules which is what a
society is you cannot do this
you you just simply cannot do this um
it's cheating at the ultimate level you
know what i mean like it would be like
you know being a baseball pitcher and
and scuffing the ball you just can't do
it you can't do it and if you do it you
need you can't play anymore it's as
simple as that you've sullied the game
and that's what this person has done and
they did it for political purposes and
it's just fairly obvious to me they they
did it uh to distract from what the
democrats are doing and
the silver lining however is that it
seems like they may have done it a
little bit too early right the midterms
are still in november they've got
everybody ginned up now and you can you
can expand and extend rage and outrage
you can do it for a while and people can
be out on the streets and angry and
everything else but i don't know how
long elizabeth warren can scream like
that i don't know how long joe biden can
lie like that and and the more that they
go crazy on abortion
literally as i said they're pushing for
an eight and nine month abortion bill
right now that's what they want
federally who are the people that want
to control you the people who would just
want to kick it back to the states and
let you decide or the people who are
demanding demanding that anyone could
just get an abortion at any time which
we all know i mean i showed you the poll
yesterday from msnb frequency 80 of
people don't want third trimester
abortions um
but this is what the machine does i
don't know what that is so i don't think
you're a conspiracy theorist unless you
think i'm a conspiracy theorist in which
case we're all conspiracy conspiracy
theorists except two years ago everyone
who's a conspiracy theorist turned out
to be right um so i don't know what that
is i don't know how it all works
you know it's like we have all these
pieces of the puzzle but we don't know
how to put it together fully because we
don't know what the puzzle looks like um
but the best we can do is stay sane be a
little bit better than them and keep
fighting for what we believe in but yes
there will be more twists and turns
because i think that this thing is just
done
too early
it's done too early and not to put like
total fear of everything in you but one
of the things that trump was talking
about last night was how he focused
mostly on the election as i said but
then he was really talking about how
russia would have never happened under
him that you know people kept saying he
was colluding with russia but russia did
absolutely nothing under him and and
there was peace and you know we were
talking to north korea and all these
things
and he repeatedly said how uh putin has
been
he keeps saying hey you know i've got
nukes i've got nukes i've got nukes and
it's like man long time to the election
like
i'm not putting that out in ether i'm
just saying like there's just the system
does weird things to keep the system
going watch the matrix cs cooper says i
recall you mentioning an australia
international tour is that still in the
cards i'm keen to hear your stand up in
person uh i don't think we're gonna do
an international thing prob maybe in the
fall i don't think we can do it till
then because when i get back i leave
next week for the west coast tour and
then i just need a little bit of time at
home before before the babies and
just to get life in order and everything
else and we've only got a couple weeks
left so i think maybe we can pull off
something in the fall it was also very
hard to organize the tour because of
masks and vaccines in certain countries
certain people don't like that
paperwork and stuff
so i didn't want to create a whole
situation so that was going to be tricky
uh but i will tell you i've freaking
loved being out on the road again and
making you guys laugh and getting out
there and doing the one second hug and
everything uh the remaining shows by the
way they're all like 90 sold out couple
tickets at each one uh and of course the
big one is june 2nd in orlando with ron
desantis dragon says i'm planning on
attending the oxnard show that's with
larry elder got vip tickets pretty
pumped to meet you as well sir which of
the major themes of the book will you
and larry be focusing on you know
i swear to you i do a different show
every night so i try not to plan it
until really about five ten minutes
before i'm sitting in the green room and
you know people are there and you can
kind of feel the energy in there and
then i just kind of have like a moment
basically i'm just kind of sitting in
the green room michael's usually in
there he's got a binder you have a
binder i don't even know what's in the
binder but he's usually flipping through
papers and doing something and i'm kind
of sitting there i have a little bit of
iced coffee before i go on stage and
then i just kind of figure out what i
want to do i usually i have like some
kind of opening line to go out there
with if something happened that day or
if i just you know i peek out into the
crowd and i can see what's going on or
something like that um but i mess around
with the crowd for a while i do my thing
we do some giveaways it's a little bit
of stand up a little bit of lecture and
i think you know with larry you know
obviously we will dive into that moment
we will dive into that that very famous
black conservative destroys libtard
moment uh from many years ago and
probably talk about how our paths you
know larry always tells me every time i
see him he's like dave you're not
everywhere i go people always say i
found you
larry elder through reuben and i'm like
larry everywhere i go people say reuben
i found you through larry elder and like
our paz then moved together and how cool
that you know five years after he
smacked me down about systemic racism
like i was opening for the guy as he was
running for governor of california like
what an awesome story that is that's
that's a cool story if there were any
actual journalists left in america like
what a cool story that is about how we
we these two separate people who by
their definition should have nothing in
common how we sort of came together and
and a friendship and then and then a
governor run and all of this stuff and
then one of us fled cali one of us is
still fighting for cali like little
thing that would be something to write a
book about i guess i guess i could write
a book about that do i have anything
happening tomorrow
i am an author i'm a guy like me all
right we'll see anyway it'll it'll be
different every night we shall see what
happens so that's oxnard uh the night
before i'm in brea with uh mr dennis
prager uh margot says besides your
annual august vacation are you planning
any down time before the munchkins
arrive seems like you've been going
non-stop and you could probably use some
quality rest
before then well
everyone keeps telling me i'm not going
to sleep anymore when these babies
arrive
you know i'm a pretty early riser i
usually i'm up at about seven a.m and my
my day has begun and i'm ready to roll
you know i loved being out on the road
this this eight shows eight cities eight
night thing i loved it i tried to you
know on the planes i'm pretty good about
taking a little nap so i was not tired
during any of it i tried to hit the gyms
in the morning i even had a two-day gym
operation one day uh we basically eat
right because you know the shows are at
like seven eight o'clock so i have a
light dinner around five i never drink
before a show ever ever period and by
the time the show's wrapped up after the
meet and greet and everything you know
it's like 11 12 o'clock
so i'm not you know maybe i'd have a
drink after one or two nights we went
out for a drink but you know i'm not
eating after that so i feel like diet
wise i felt good i was able to you know
sometimes i'll try to take a little nap
in the afternoon if possible but i felt
like a million bucks when i came home i
really did and i loved every second of
it and i'm looking forward to to getting
back out there so no uh we'll do the off
the grid august thing again but baby
number one comes in august so this is
going to be a little different than
usual i suspect
uh i will have to have
some kind of phone situation i have an
old iphone that we've removed all the
apps from that can operate maybe just as
a phone so that you know i can reach
someone on a phone call or a text or
something like that even though i don't
even want to look at any of the things
in august but this is a little bit
different this time but no we have no no
plans beyond that just we're really just
trying to get the house in order and fix
up some things here we got we got
painters here today they're painting a
nursery and the other uh the other wing
over there uh janis says are you still
considering adopting a second dog oh man
i hope your home is filled with more
love than ever before with all the new
additions to your family i think we're
on operation pause on second dog you
know it's funny someone asked me that on
a q a a couple weeks ago and i i like
blurred it out out of nowhere i was like
maybe we'll get a second dog
david came up to me later in the day and
said we are not getting a second dog he
said you do know we have two children
coming um clyde could use a friend he's
he's been i've told you he's been a
little nutty around here with the
lizards and the iguanas and the snakes
and the peacocks he's sort of nuts our
our trainer is actually downstairs right
now working working him
so he could use a friend to like get
some of that extra energy out but i
think a second dog at the moment is
probably
probably a bit much uh carol says do you
plan on attending the nat con set for
miami i attended last time only because
you douglas murray glenn lowery and
carol swain attended um you know i
didn't even know when is the next one
when is the one in miami netcon miami um
i will gladly go if they invite me and
actually i just interviewed a day or two
ago joram hazoni
who has written a new book all about the
ideas of national conservatism we're
going to put that up in a week or so you
know we taped it for when i go back out
on the road i'm being told it's october
31st to november 2nd which is actually
exactly the same days it was last year
and if i'm invited i i would be happy to
go and what they're really trying to do
at nat con is much of what i talk about
on this show can you
can oh that was last year's dates i was
going to say it's a little odd that's
the exact same dates we'll see if we can
get the dates uh but what they're trying
to do at nakan
is is say can all of us who are
anti-woke can we create a movement what
does that movement look like can the
religious conservatives exist with the
ex-libs and the libertarians and all
this stuff can that thing hold
i don't know what the answer is i
discussed this with douglas murray in
our interview that we put up last week
it's like that is a tough thing to do we
can all sort of get together right now
and be like defeat the woke but then
we're gonna have all sorts of problems
on the other side so we may as well
start talking about those problems now
that's why i was so proud to be there
and peter thiel opened up the conference
and then some of the people you
mentioned were there was just great oh
okay i'm being told it is september 11th
to 13th
of this fall so yeah i'll see if they
invite me
i will go
ron says how do you think we as regular
citizens can push back on the banks and
their initiatives i think mostly what
you're referring to is this esg stuff
that glenn beck has been talking about
this is what his whole book in many ways
the great reset is about that we're
going to have these social credit scores
i mean this stuff is coming it is coming
and depending on how you behave and what
you protest and what you don't protest
and what you say about the government
and all these things it seems that these
corporations are going to be giving us
scores and depending on your score might
affect your ability to get a mortgage it
might affect your ability to uh get a
loan for a car etc etc etc all sorts of
things it might affect your ability to
rent an apartment if the building
doesn't want you know if your score your
your social score is too low they may
not want you in there um it's dangerous
stuff and i think the best thing we can
do is i don't know that we can fully
stop it from happening at the existing
institutions it seems they've been
infected the way they've been infected
by wokism but what we can do is build
new things and that's what we've been
doing that's what we're doing with
rumble
that's what all sorts of people are
doing i mean that's what bitcoin is all
about that's what decentralization is
all about
i would say diversify a little bit you
know i go a bit into finances in dumper
in this country i'm a big believer in
things that you should put most of your
money into things so i like putting
money into real estate i just think
we've made some good moves related to
houses
because i believe if you own something i
like paying my mortgage i know it sounds
kind of crazy but when mortgage rates
are low and i know they're getting worse
right now
but if you get a low mortgage rate when
you are paying your mortgage every month
you're basically paying yourself and
then you're paying a tiny bit of
interest on top of that but hopefully
the goal is that when you sell the house
you're getting all of that money back
plus the profit that you make on the
house right so i i just believe in
things more than just sort of investing
in a gajillion other things i don't do
that obviously i put a lot of my sweat
equity and some of my money into locals
which then merge with rumble um but in
terms of the banks specifically um you
know people are going to now smaller
credit unions and not doing everything
with citibank and chase and everything
else find a bank that's a little more in
line with your values um i don't want to
sit here and endorse any specific bank
um but there there are ways to do it
there are ways to do it but you really
got to think it you got to think it
clearly it's weird we're in this
we're watching the end of an old world
and the birth of a new world and that's
what so much of this is about uh you
know for for the question earlier about
the conspiracy theory stuff it's like it
feels like there's this evil thing
moving on us at all the time
at all times but perhaps this is just
the natural function of an old world
dying in a new world being born so
that's why it feels so crazy maybe it's
not all totally coordinated by something
that i don't really understand or we
don't know what it is or the world
economic forum like maybe it's just the
collapse of old things and a certain set
of people aging out and a new world that
was uh that is starting and it was more
connected to people that were younger
when the internet was in its early
stages and and that these things are
colliding with each other and that's
what's causing so much of the chaos uh
but that there will be new banks i mean
there really will be there will be new
banks there will be decentralized
wallets and a whole bunch more
um kathy says phoenix roll with me uh
which will be worse for the left row
being overturned or trump's return to
twitter well
look the roe thing is happening short of
this leak causing such upheaval that
potentially john roberts i suppose flips
his decision um and perhaps that's why
this thing was leaked so the it does
sound like roe is being overturned i
really really hope that commer heads
prevail in this and that people realize
what the decision was
and that that abortion itself is not a
constitutional right but that has
nothing to do with where we started
today's show that suddenly you'd be able
to discriminate
against people because of their
sexuality or because of their skin color
or as that farting [ __ ] eric swalwell
who slept with the chinese spy yes it's
true google it said that the next thing
they'll be coming for is interracial
marriage these people are complete
maniacs so i do hope that that calmer
heads prevail on that uh so which will
be worse left row being overturned or
trump's return to twitter well look
trump is saying he's not going back on
twitter uh trump is saying he's going
all in on truth social you know he has
this company dwack behind it which you
know they're they're doing a spack i
don't want to get too into all the how
the spac works but it's basically like a
holding company that leads your company
uh to go fully public so he's got all of
this money and his investors that have
gone in on dwack and it and it its stock
price went crazy high so if he was to
somehow back out of that
it would create a lot of problems for a
lot of people around him so my guess is
he's probably just going to do the true
thing the question also is does he end
up running does he not run like is he
going to be more of a businessman in the
future is he going to be more of a voice
is he going to be a politician all of
those things but which would make them
all crazier
there is nothing on this world as much
as they love dead babies
there is nothing in this world that
would make them crazier than donald
trump's return to twitter so we shall
see
guys real quick reminder i will be in
orlando with the gov the gov of america
ron desantis on june 2nd you can get
tickets at daverubin.com
events i'm pretty sure vip is already
sold out but some general admission
tickets remain uh part two of my
interview with former cia operative
brian dean wright really fascinating
stuff is up on rumble and locals right
now uh rumbling youtube right now the
full things up of course ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
and uh speaking of twitter
speaking of making people crazy
our cold close today
is
the scariest man in all of the world
the man who is sending us to space and
giving us electric cars
and now saving free speech very very
scary elon musk
[Applause]
oh